luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys anna welcome
back to the lehigh pen show um let me know if
you can hear me okay because i have changed
my mic so it should be a little different to
usual so when you guys comment i've got all the
comments on so i can see everything um coming
through okay so this show is a little different um
a little bit nervous because it's a bit different
um was also quite last minute um because i'd
just been working on my book all day um had no
makeup on my face whatsoever so i thought okay
i'll just throw something on and just do this
show okay so before we jump in um of course it is
powered by um icon plus capital it is sponsored
by um block fi so you can actually get up to 250
um when you sign up i hope i wrote that correctly
um an actual new sponsor that i have this week is
compass so some quick information about compass so
basically um compass they are a company that make
bitcoin mining accessible for everyone so you can
actually get a machine pick a hosting facility
and let them do the work so if you do want um
some kind of bitcoin mining facility then
definitely head to compassmining.io so they
are the newest sponsors on my show so it's really
exciting okay so i said i'd do an ama so that's
what i'm gonna do we're also gonna talk about my
book which i've been rewriting today actually um
because i had a change of heart about a few things
so this is totally live as you guys know this is
completely unprepared it was a really last minute
so i'm gonna head over to twitter now and have a
look at some of the questions that you guys sent
me because yeah this is totally live unprepared
have a thought about haven't even looked at the
questions yet it's just been such a hectic day
so let's have a look okay so crypto chris so made
a shout out to cryptochrist because he is great he
always um interacts with everything love his takes
so he asks what my favorite books are fiction and
non-fiction okay so somebody actually asked me
this the other day did someone very blink if
this is live this is totally live and unprepared
i haven't even seen the questions yet so i'm just
doing it as they as they come to me okay so
favorite book somebody asked this um the other
day so i'm actually really into um i don't know if
i'd call it spirituality but i'm definitely into
like the mind body connection and how um your your
every every everything that you feel physically is
a result of what's going on in your mind so one
of my favorite books is actually the biology of
belief and mind over medicine so that comes from
a very personal story i had a bunch of health
issues when i was younger and i read those books
and i'm amazing i'm all happy and healthy today
um in terms of other books um i'm actually not a
huge reader when i read it's to learn something so
like i said biology of belief was to help with
my physical life um and then i absolutely love
all the bitcoin books um i'm a big fan of um
bitcoin and black america um by isaiah jackson
that was so fascinating love jason williams's
book if you guys haven't seen that check it out
um you know hard money you can't f with i'm not
gonna swear because this is youtube um so yeah
those are some of my some of my favorite books
somebody said did your brother sell his bitcoin
for ethereum actually my brother owes me a lot
of money and he's gonna have to sell his bitcoin
to pay me back this money um which i will tell you
all about another time i asked him to tell me more
information about this and if i can post about it
but he won't let me do it yet but i'm definitely
gonna have him on the podcast so stay tuned for
that because my brother is quite a [ __ ] coiner
um he can't help it he was once up like a few
weeks ago um like at the top of the bull market
back in april he was up 70 grand on some coin
he didn't sell it he's now totally minus so so
there you go he's a he's a bit of a [ __ ] coiner
he'd message me because he was in the states and
i was in um the uk he'd message me at like 1am
my time leo you need to get in on this on this
thing it's called like moon this and you know it's
kind of rubbish so i obviously didn't buy it um
so that's a story about my brother okay
so i'm going through some of the questions
someone says in all serious though comparing with
the past bear markets how long will this one last
do i think okay we can definitely talk about
this market okay so look as you guys know
it's obviously impossible to tell what kind of
market um we're in um if you want to talk about
um you know price depreciation everybody
was was expecting some kind of correction
um off the top of my head again this is all
totally unprepared um i would say this is the most
bullish bear market i have seen um i think what
we've seen right now is absolutely unbelievable um
with what we've seen going on with el
salvador the rest of central and south america
um you know i think china is a really really
interesting topic to be honest the china topic
i think um is good news i'm happy to talk about
that as well because a lot of people have been
um you know saying this is this is terrible what
we're seeing with china and i think it's great um
for two main reasons one of the main reasons i
feel this is great is because one of the biggest
issues that bitcoin often comes under when it
you know when it's scrutinized and all this is
centralization people say that it's centralized
in china and this fudd is regurgitated again
and again and in some ways this is amazing for
the decentralization of the network um we've
already seen many different mining companies
talking about moving to kazakhstan moving to um
canada moving to the us miami this is great for
the decentralization of the network um i'm just
reading some of your comments now i'm getting this
is really hard by the way to like do a live and
read the comments and read everything that's going
on i've never done this before so this is this is
kind of strange um so there you go those are those
are my thoughts is my thoughts on china oh and
also another point as to why this is a good thing
so clearly china has an effect on the market this
is very much an immature market um bitcoin is only
12 years old we've seen us very much correlated to
geopolitical events to some extent of course it
recovered after the crash in 2020 but it's not
immune just yet um and so i feel china has less
control over the price or less influence over the
price in that short term um you know especially
if there's less mining going on there so
just reading the comments people are saying
nice things thanks it's a it's stressful this is
stressful um so yeah there you go those are those
are my brief thoughts on china i don't think it's
an issue um i was talking about this actually with
jason williams the other day um we were sort of
saying that things will take time to recover um
you know you don't just plug in a mining machine
and it's all just okay although these major
operations are leaving china and they're moving to
other places building that kind of infrastructure
takes time but i have zero worries the difficulty
adjustment adjusts i love saying that i think it
sounds really fun um and i think it's great as
well the mining rewards have gone up i don't know
if you guys have seen that actually the mining
rewards have gone up i think at one point um i
don't know what it was but the mining rewards not
that it's gone up but miners now more miners are
um have more access to the rewards right because
there's less competition on the market which is
pretty cool so what's happened with china has
has incentivized more people to get involved i
think that's great help decentralize the network
more all right i'm going to keep going and have a
look at some other questions and then i'm going to
go into my book because i said i'd answer that
all right let's have a look what we have what
do you spend the majority of your money on each
month oh my god that is such a good question um
i would say unfortunately alcohol and coffee is
that absolutely awful um and food i just i think
i like going out for breakfast so like avocado
eggs coffee and then wine in the afternoon olives
i'm pretty european like that um that's
pretty much what i spent my money on but
i actually said once i've completed my book and
once it's done i'm going to reward myself by
um by buying face creams i mean i feel like that's
you just reach an age where you know you want to
get yourself some luxurious face creams that's
what i want to do so that's what i'm gonna do um
it's pretty expensive actually but that's how
i'm gonna spend my money next month all right
let's have a look what else we have are you still
thinking of moving out the country okay so moving
countries is difficult especially um after brexit
so with brexit for those who aren't european um
someone says i think this isn't live this is live
okay i haven't even seen any of your questions
i'm totally just winging this because i've been
working all day i haven't had a chance to do
anything so i'm win it winning so i can't got
my words out winging this okay so after brexit
um for those that don't know um when you lived in
an eu country you have what is called freedom of
movement so before brexit as a uk citizen i had
the right to pick up my stuff and live in any eu
country as they did have the right to come to
an um to come to the uk from whatever country
you came from um after brexit that is now
not possible we can only do three months
in a particular country if i want to live there
um you have to go through the whole immigration
process which is a nightmare so in terms of
where i want to live i'm totally undecided
and um i don't want to go through a whole
immigration process to go somewhere and then to
decide actually i don't want to live there um so i
really kind of want to embrace the bitcoin digital
nomad kind of lifestyle um whereby i do three
months here i do three months there um and it's
so much more exciting like that especially because
right now the world is changing so much um i'm in
love with what el salvador have done i'm totally
open to spending some time in el salvador um i'm
so open to it i can't even tell you um and so why
would i want to go through an entire immigration
process for a particular country when what if the
country suddenly becomes a really anti-crypto you
know what if the country um goes into a lockdown
the world is so unpredictable that i don't want
to be i don't want to be tied to a certain country
you know i have the right to live in the uk as a
um as a citizen that's been born and raised here
so you know i'm fortunate enough to have that
um but i'm definitely gonna do some traveling so
the goal is actually um and then we can get onto
my book but i do wanna answer more questions um
so the uh so the goal is um essentially to come
to miami that's what i want to do so i want to get
to miami um around the middle of august so there's
actually a conference in november around the 10th
11th of november which i will be hosting um and
it's in miami so i'm only allowed to spend three
months in america so that means that i've got to
get to miami just after the middle of august so
because i don't know if you know but uk citizens
aren't actually allowed to fly directly to america
right now because of covid um so what that means
is i have to then fly to mexico spend two more two
weeks in mexico and then go to the states so when
i'm there i wanna do um a book launch i wanna
do a major meet up um so if you're interested
then let me know in the comments where i should
do this meet up i'm thinking of doing it in miami
um and just hanging out there um and that's
what i want to do and then i might go to texas
um and do a meet-up there do maybe like
some kind of book launch book signing
um so that's my thought process for traveling okay
so someone's asked a really interesting question
i'm gonna put it on the screen so you guys can
read it and then i'm gonna take a drink of water
because this is totally live and this
is so i'm unpredictable all right
what do you think will
happen with banks and crypto
it's a really great question one which i've
actually addressed in my book on dressing bitcoin
okay so here's my take so today we just heard so
today is um for those re-watching it is the eighth
of july how time flies so um we've actually just
heard that um santander are now the second bank
in the uk to block um payments from finance so
obviously barclays was first and uh santander
was second so i think this is sad and i think it's
a shame and i think it's really really upsetting
take is that people only ban what they fear
and china is a fantastic example of that
you know china ban bitcoin because they fear it
china ban twitter because they fear it trying
to buy many different things because they fear
it so we understand that banning is done because
they fear it and i tweeted about this yesterday
it's so much more than bitcoin it's so much more
than an alternative way for me it's about freedom
and there is this looming war on freedom and
i think we've seen that with covet anyway um
you know with all the lockdowns and how different
countries have approached it differently
just as an example you know some countries you
have to wear a mask outside other countries
you know of course you don't have to wear a mask
outside it makes no sense for the science you know
um we've seen florida and texas have stayed
open and nobody's dropping dead to dying um
you know nobody's dropping dead over there so what
we'll see is certain institutions states provinces
organizations will have to pick
aside as we continue to move forward
everything right now is strange um you know
whether it's the whether it's um in politics
with the olympics you know we see trans women
in females female sports we're not allowed to
criticize that hence war on speech freedom of
speech um war and money with banks and so on and
so on so basically what i'm getting at is that
we are going through a really interesting time
we've been told that we will
eventually get to a point whereby we're
this is what they've said to us they've said to
us you will own nothing and you will be happy
what do you mean we will own nothing
what do you mean how does that make sense
surely i should own what i choose to own
that's a war on individual freedom already
we're and we've been going down this path
for a really long time i mean we know this
editor from the the messages that i received
um after that tweet so what's gonna happen
banks institutions countries provinces states
will have to pick a side cbdc's will come
they will try and replace bitcoin you can't
actually ban a network like that which we've
obviously spoken about many different times but
they will try and propaganda and marketing will be
a huge huge part of this i mean covert has its own
damn marketing campaign vaccines have a marketing
campaign cbdc's will have a marketing campaign
and it's our job our responsibility to make sure
that those who are not inside or not involved in
the cryptocurrency industry understand that they
are different and cbdc's are highly centralized
they are not this new shiny form of money which
is going to make life better which is how i
believe it will be sold as um there will be a
war between but a subtle one right like when i say
when i when i talk about this war that i envisage
it's not an obvious war it's not like men on the
streets men in the trenches men on the fields
it's not that anymore it's a subtle war between
the people and those in control those in power
and it's our responsibility to continue to
fight that there will it there will be an
increased crackdown on it and like i said states
organizations provinces countries will have to
pick a side and it's really really interesting i
think russia actually i read yesterday so i don't
fully know the situation there but russia their
politicians are talking about implementing new
legislation which would allow governments to um
seize people's cryptocurrencies but it's not clear
yet whether that will be cryptocurrencies um which
are specifically involved in illegal activity or
cryptocurrencies in general or cryptocurrencies
that they suspect have been involved in illegal
activity what do you mean suspect it's
concerning there will be a war between
the two sides i'm convinced of it and the war
is starting like i said it's gonna be subtle
anyway i'm going to keep reading someone says
speak your truth i will always speak my truth
okay let's have a look at the questions that i
have like i said guys this is totally live also i
didn't mention um maybe i did but i don't remember
oh i did mention it but i'll say it again this is
powered by i'm the vc firm icon plus capital so
i just want to make everybody aware of that okay
let's have a look oh gosh i was about to read
something out which is rude um okay let's keep
going um why aren't you married yet um i'm
not married yet because i am in my mid-20s
and i will be married one day at some point
okay did you ever use btc to buy things um
not exactly so i work with um crypto.com so they
sponsor somebody tweet some of my tweets um but
crypto.com are fantastic like i've been i only
partnered with them about a month ago so june i
believe was my first month um partnering with them
but i've been using them for over a year i think
since march last year so huge fan of the company
um so in terms of do i spend my bitcoin okay so
sometimes when somebody sends me bitcoin like
i i settle balances with friends and family
in bitcoin so they'll send me bitcoin and then i
will top up my crypto.com card and then spend so
in that way i spend bitcoin other than that not
really honestly um what i i get paid mostly in
bitcoin so um i work a lot with altcoin buzz and
exodus wallet um so they pay all their employees
in bitcoin which is really cool so i get paid
in bitcoin um so what i tend to do is sell it
to an extent so that i can pay my bills on
my fixes um so that's the extent of my paying
in bitcoin um other than that not really i
live in england there's nowhere to directly
buy things you know you could say people use um
you know like paypal or something like that to
pay for things in bitcoin but it's really just an
intermediary which switches to fiat so it's the
same as crypto.com and that it switches to fiat
and then you spend it um so not really no okay
reading more stuff let's have a look okay oh
my god so many questions coming through this is
great thank you so much for watching um somebody
asked how can we get more women into crypto um
everyone watching do you know my opinion on this
before i potentially discuss it so somebody asks
how do we get more women into crypto
do you guys know my opinion on this
i have a pretty harsh opinion on the situation
so obviously the comments are on let me know
okay what is my opinion on this
really it's just a question why
do we need more women in crypto
why do we need more women in crypto i don't know
why i don't think we need more anyone in anything
i think we need more competent qualified qualified
people that add value to the space that is what we
need i don't want more people i don't want more
women in anything just because they're women
not all women women don't offer an alternative
perspective just because they're women like
absolutely not i actually have a very masculine
um outlook on life a typically masculine outlook
on life does that mean suddenly my opinion
is invalid because it's not a female opinion
no i don't offer a female perspective i i really
do not offer a traditional female perspective
so adding and i'm also you know women are supposed
to be creative and add a nice feminine touch i'm
not like that i'm actually not very creative
at all i'm very facts and figures and i like
to follow strategies and i don't like to
create i'm really not good at creating so
the traditional or ideal value that a woman
offers to this space i don't believe that i
that i bring at all i think i bring what the men
bring the same the same kind of thing except i
look a little bit different maybe if you guys
enjoy looking at long hair then there you go
but from uh from a different from this kind of
standpoint i don't offer any different value
because i'm a woman whatsoever um like i said
everything that i offer really is i i'm very
masculine in that sense you know like i like
structure and i like i like looking at like
the facts and the figures and i like following um
plans and details i don't like to create and add
that typical feminine um perspective so really
we need more we need more competent people that
add value whether they're women or not that's
great for me i don't really care honestly same
goes with religion same goes with race i'm just
not interested at all um and also just because
a woman is in a space doesn't mean that that will
represent other women you know this is 50 of the
population we're talking about gender does not
uh put us um gender does not align us it doesn't
it doesn't make us the same um there's a lot of
women in the space who um i have zero things in
common with um have more i think more things in
common with men so yeah gender is ridiculous all
right let's see what else we have here um okay
very nice okay i'm gonna go back to my twitter
what is your ultimate financial goal
not mentioning one specific asset okay
how long have i been live 22 minutes okay all
right i'm gonna just take a little breather
and then um i'm gonna talk about undressing
bitcoin okay so like i said this is totally live
was a little bit stressed out been working all
day and um couldn't think about what i was what
i was going to do for the show um didn't read
any of the questions beforehand i just figured
what will we all be okay so someone asks
let me read again what are your ultimate
financial goals not to mention okay my
financial goals okay good question look
it's not a financial goal it's more just like a
life goal the life goal is freedom freedom has
always been my goal um i have zero problem
with personal responsibility in fact i love
personal responsibility my goal is to
live a happy beautiful and free life
um whereby the weekends are full of adventure the
days are full of adventure you know i love nature
whether that's going out and you know going to
lakes watching the sunsets going to the beach
i love nature and i want my days to be full
of nature and a lot of the time in order to
kind of live that kind of lifestyle you have to
have money to do what you want to do so the goal
is financial freedom i don't want my money to
be in um custody of somebody else if you guys
have been following me you'll know that revolut
blocked my bank sorry revolut blocks my friends
revolut are my bank their mother fintech company
um but they they blocked my funds tonight move
a bit and get a little bit comfier so yeah
revolut blocked my funds and that is awful
right that is so bad i had a lot of money
in these accounts and they blocked it and so
somebody says i seem to have a problem with
authority that's funny i don't i'm just very
much pro-freedom which i think is a wonderful
wonderful thing um why do i need authority i am
my own authority i'm very um i trust myself to
navigate my own life i don't need somebody who
knows nothing about me to navigate my life i
only i can navigate my life um to the best of
its ability um so revolut blocks my funds um long
story short um i don't back with them anymore but
because i had money in cryptocurrency held in
a non-custodial way i was able to survive um
like i said i get paid in bitcoin so the majority
of my wealth is in crypto um is in bitcoin so
because i had money in bitcoin i was okay but
those who don't hold their money in that manner
those who are not financially sovereign who are
who could be in my situation where banks freeze
you know your business account your personal
account it's pretty sad so my goal is
absolutely financial freedom someone says but
don't you enjoy the adventure of financial freedom
and if you achieved what else
you're gonna do besides no like
okay here's my thing okay here's my
thing you know how we all used to
be cave men and women right and the men would
go out and we all lived in nature the men would
go out they would um they would kill the animals
bring back the food and everything right we all
used to live in those those times before not even
not even cave men times we talked about the stone
age and all that i'm talking about like back in
the day okay everything was very much in nature we
don't have the kind of houses that we have today
and have the technology that we have today but
i think we're going to go back to that because
of technology because of things like covert
which has shown us we don't need to commute
and go into the office and things like that
with this increased technology that
we have we're going to go back to that
and that's kind of what i want to do you know
that digital nomad lifestyle where they live
in beautiful places and all this stuff they're
going back to that except they have wi-fi now
and i kind of want i kind of want that like i want
to be out in the wild i want to be i want to do my
work with amazing wi-fi and all this stuff and
then once my day is done i want to go and have
an adventure in nature that is my goal back how it
used to be back in the day before all technology
and stuff and that is freedom and i think
that's what like you know things like bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies and this new technology
that we have i think that's what it will do
people living in like listen i was i
was out in london the other night okay
it was empty it was a friday night and it was
empty why was it empty we're not in lockdown
anymore why was it empty because what's the point
like people aren't living in the center of the
city anymore because because of covert because
they've all gone back home they don't need to live
right around the corner from the office
there's going to be a huge exodus from the city
back into nature and that's what i'm excited
for okay i'm gonna talk about my book now
so if you have any questions about my book
please just um write them oh i'm still here
let me just change my camera hang on i'm
still here there we go take a sip of water
okay
oh this is really strange i have never done
this before feels weird okay i am totally live
all right so my book okay so it's called
undressing bitcoin and here's the thing
i love this industry i've just spoken for about
28 minutes and 11 seconds about freedom personal
responsibility being self-sovereign and all the
things that i love and support and appreciate now
because i love it so much i want to spread
adoption i want people to know about this
revolutionary technology what upsets me is that
i feel that right now there's really this huge
barrier to entry forget physical barriers to
entries to entry like um on and off rams and
barclays and santander and all this stuff that i
discussed at the beginning um but a philosophical
and technological barrier to entry it's hard
to understand what this space is really about
you know if you just say freedom to somebody i
think you're a conspiracy theorist you know if you
say it's your friends down the road i believe in
freedom so i'm leaving the traditional financial
system it's hard for people to understand
they'll literally think you are a conspiracy
theorist um it's also very hard to verbalize the
problems with the traditional financial system
to put forward the case for inflation it's
hard do you have the numbers off the top of
your head i'm writing this down book and i don't
even have the numbers off the top of my head
actually i do because i wrote something a
minute ago but it's really really hard and
the technology is hard understanding the
the importance of decentralization that is
really really hard understanding things like
um mining it's a whole new language hash rate
you know difficulty adjustment i mean what the
hell are these things it's so hard but like these
things are what makes bitcoin so genius and you
know the elegance of the technology which makes it
the most incredible piece of technology we've
ever seen so these things are hard so my idea is
to basically put together a book which explains
it and i want the book to be full of fun like i
want it to be spicy i want it to have personality
i want to have flavor and i want it to be full of
so much fun and i want you to be able to take this
book and say yeah read undressing bitcoin it's
actually bloody great and you can fully understand
the problems of the traditional financial system
and you probably have it off while you
while you read it as well you know like
there's such a gate there's such gatekeeping
and there's such difficulties to get involved
it's hard to understand what this technology is
really about and so i want yes somebody's wrote
a knowledge barrier i mean that's exactly it you
know it's so hard for people to understand so i
and it's boring to some people okay so here
it is because my excitement for this space
comes from freedom and my love for freedom and
understanding this looming authoritarianism
that's coming so i ideally if people don't feel
that way they'll find it really really boring
so i want to add as much flavor and excitement to
it that's basically the goal and um it's going to
be very different it's going to be um it's going
to be very unfiltered and it's going to be quite
potentially controversial because it's what
it's going to say what we're all thinking so
i actually rewrote the first chapter today and in
that first chapter i'm basically roasting everyone
so i posted this on my twitter and um
people thought oh oh you're roasting
us on twitter absolutely not you guys are
great i'm not roasting you lot i'm roasting
the federal reserve i'm roasting jerome powell
that's how you pronounce his name i'm roasting
the education system um i'm roasting the um bank
of england everything all the systems are getting
roasted in that first chapter okay a lot of
people would um or how i initially wrote it
was very much tipping tippy-toeing yeah
i'm like you know walking on thin ice
um as you go through this but screw that
honestly it's gonna be so unfiltered
um and um yeah it's gonna be completely unfiltered
and i'm gonna say what the hell i fancy saying um
there's gonna be a lot of sarcasm in the book um
it's gonna be very witty um yeah there's one line
um when i talk about money laundering and i make a
joke yeah there's just so many jokes somebody has
said let's have a look how many contributors
in your book no contributors it's just me
it's just me and it's been really really difficult
um i actually wrote the book during the lockdown
um and um i actually yeah i wrote it during the
lockdown so it's actually like pretty depressing
time to write a book um so looking back on it
now i'm definitely adding more flavor and more
energy to it um so the book cover is also really
exciting um like i said i want to my goal is to um
it'll not necessarily follow all the rules um
i just want to do what i want to do um i don't
necessarily because i'm just going to be me
and i don't necessarily want to try and fit in
you know um should i try and fit in and be
potentially i don't know like i don't want to
be dull with things you know i want to be exciting
with things and i don't want to um i don't want to
play by the rules i don't want to do what
everybody else has done i really just wanna be
i wanna be uncensored and true to my personality
and true to me um and that's how the book will be
the book will be totally unfiltered true to me
it's gonna be completely different to all the
other books um and yeah i just i want it to be
fun and exciting okay so when's it coming out
um so initially um the book was supposed to come
out at the end of july which it might still do
um but like i said i'm actually going over it to
add more flavor and i feel like one of the things
is because you care so much about this and i've
actually never written a book before but because
i care so much about this and i really want to
make sure that and also it's an academic subject
i want to make sure that all the information is
there so going back i've noticed that um going
back i noticed that i put too many examples in
okay and i need to take those out there's so many
examples of inflation i don't need it there are
so many examples of how bitcoin can't be banned
and more news keeps coming out so i was going to
write something about china and i was like you
know i already made the damn point move the hell
on so that's the hard part of the book because
you want to you want it to be so perfect and
um someone says put too many what too many
examples too many examples to illustrate a point
so i go over and over so i was like no no i need
to delete that so it's really at this point it's
really just a matter of um cutting all the fat and
getting to the point cutting straight to the
chase um so yeah i'm spending quite a lot of
time right now just going through all of that um
cutting it all back and making sure that i have um
illustrated the point in the most exciting fun
sarcastic sassy manner as possible because i
feel like we need it i feel like this space
just needs it okay so can you buy it in bitcoin
go gotta take a drink silence is quite interesting
just letting the silence you know just settle
it's very interesting okay where can you
buy it so initially i was thinking um
to entirely self publish um so i was going to
create a shopify website um where you could
buy it in bitcoin um but i decided against that
um and that was quite a last minute decision i
definitely i'm dinard about it for a while and the
reason that um i changed my mind is because i want
everybody to have access to this book and i
don't know what tomorrow holds i don't know
you know what if one day i get banned on
twitter um like i'm careful i try not to
what if this platform bans me you know
you just don't know um so i wanted to
make sure that everybody had access to it so
it's going to be on amazon and it's going to be
there's going to be kindle version there's
going to be a paperback version and an audio
version um the audio version obviously i haven't
done yet because i haven't finished tweaking the
book i say tweaking i'm basically rewriting it at
this point because i just have some other ideas i
want to like switch it up um so yeah it's gonna be
on amazon so unless you can buy bitcoin buy stuff
on amazon with bitcoin i don't think you'll be
able to buy my book with bitcoin um unless maybe
you don't like through paypal like i was talking
about earlier you know um that's kind of the only
way that i can think about it um okay so the
cover okay so i'm not gonna tell you what the
cover's like just yet you guys i might actually
put um a vote out because there are two that i
really like um but the one that i have in mind
it's have you guys seen the film um molly's game
let me know if you've seen it it's basically very
casino vibes this woman starts this um this big
gambling thing and anyway it's got those vibes
it's got very vegas vibes um and yeah it's
definitely gonna be a head turner something give
me a head turner but hey who cares i want it to be
a head turner like i want to have as much fun with
it as possible you know disrupt make things happen
make it exciting i don't want to just like
like look people super successful people never
successful people always rock the boat they
never like just fit in because if you fit in
you're just gonna get lost in a crowd of
hundreds of thousands of people i don't
want my book to be lost in a crowd of hundreds of
thousands of people i spent a lot of time on this
um and it means a lot to me like i'm dedicating
this live stream to it so you know i don't want to
yeah i don't want to fit in with it um yes i will
be voicing the audio book somebody said poker in
the hotel yes that is molly's game poke it in
the hotel room so you know how like it's really
sassy and it's stylish that's the front
cover so very stylish so i'm very excited
um okay so we have been doing this for 40 minutes
now and i've been working all day so i'm super
tired so i'm gonna log off in a second but log off
do we say that anymore but um if you do have any
more questions then just drop it in the comments
section below and i will answer them all now
i'm reading your comments is it helpful
for amateurs of course look the book
is supposed to be something which you will
enjoy as somebody who's already in crypto
but also your parents will enjoy and find funny
honestly the book like i rewrote the first chapter
today and it's actually hilarious like it's
actually funny there are things that i've written
in there where i'm just like i can't believe i
just wrote that but hey it's really really funny
um oh and i said that everybody gets roasted
in the first chapter americans get roasted
in the first chapter sorry okay all right
if you have any more questions let me know
because i'm running out of water and um i
won't be able to continue once this is done
it's done all right guys i'm waiting for a few
more questions and then i'm going to head out
let's have a look what we have here you didn't
say how much bitcoin you have yeah i get paid
in bitcoin come on oh well thank you to ryan
kramer very much do i trade forex no i don't i
don't trade that's something i haven't mentioned
have i i don't trade um i mean look like okay i
trade but i don't trade how you would imagine
like leverage trading margin trading all that
stuff i don't get involved in that at all um the
reason i don't get involved in that is because um
you it requires a lot of um skill experience and
also time to watch the market in that way um oh
hang on there we go oh thank you ryan kramer
and there's another one you rock ryan everyone
follower on twitter she's fun and edgy that's nice
thank you to the ron there you go very cool um
what was i saying oh yeah so it requires a lot of
trading requires a lot of time energy skill and
so i would say to those who aren't professional
traders or who haven't spent a lot of time trading
to be very very careful when it comes to it the
trading that i do is buying a bunch of oats in a
bear market then when the alts go right up in a
bull market i sell and take my profits and live
a good life you know bitcoin i certainly don't
trade absolutely not i don't have the time the
energy to time a market i'm not in the business
to time a market that's exhausting for me i have
too much to do you know i got these shows to do i
got a book to write so yeah i certainly don't have
um the the energy to do that i totally
commend the people that do um because i
don't have it in me um maybe one day um okay i
will take one last question an amount of water
somebody says will there be any signed copies
of my book undressing bitcoin okay so just on
that point like i said i'm going to be in the
states um and you guys are more than welcome
to come to a meet-up that i'm going to host
um just obviously if you're watching me on
um twitter then i'll announce the dates and the
location of the meetup coming very very soon um
so yeah follow that on twitter i'll be mentioning
those dates and then bring the book and i will
sign it but because it's going through amazon
i won't be able to physically have a book to
send it to you and to sign so um so so yeah
i won't be able to do that unless we all meet
in person which we are more than welcome to do
in the coming few weeks when i head to america
all right my friends firstly thank you so so much
for tuning in um it's been really really cool this
is very very different i've never i never usually
do this i think i might do more of them um usually
i always have a guest and we sit down and we and
we talk about things um but this time it's it's
just me it's just leia i'm talking about my book
so it's been really really nice thank you so much
for all your engagement um it's been really really
fun i loved looking through all the comments
uh someone has just said they just tuned
in and you'll have to come back next week
because this is the end of it now but um thank
you all so much for tuning in and i will catch
you all on twitter because i have an addiction
and i'm on there too much all right bye bye